if we Republicans choose Donald Trump as
our nominee the prospects for a safe and
prosperous future are greatly diminished
if Donald Trump's plans were ever
implemented the country would sink into
prolonged recession is it he a huge
business success doesn't he know what
he's talking about no he isn't
and no he doesn't a business genius he
is not mr. Trump's bombast is already
alarming our allies let Isis take out
Assad he said and then we can pick up
the remnants this recklessness is
recklessness in the extreme now Donald
Trump tells us that he is very very
smart I'm afraid that when it comes to
foreign policy he is very very not smart
Donald Trump lacks the temperament to be
President after all this is an
individual who mocked a disabled
reporter Donald Trump says he admires
Vladimir Putin at the same time he's
called George W Bush a liar that is a
twisted example of evil trumping good
there's a dark irony in his boasts of
his sexual exploits during the Vietnam
War while at the same time John McCain
whom he has mocked was imprisoned and
tortured dishonesty is Donald Trump's
hallmark his imagination must not be
married to real power think of Donald
Trump's personal qualities the bullying
the greed the showing off the misogyny
the absurd third-grade theatrics
now mr. Trump relishes any poll that
reflects what he thinks of himself but
polls are also saying that he will lose
to Hillary Clinton of course a trump
nomination enables her victory there's
plenty of evidence that mr. Trump is a
con man a fake mr. Trump has changed his
positions not just over the years but
over the course of the campaign
and on the Ku Klux Klan daily for three
days in a row I predict that there are
more bombshells
in his tax returns I predict that he
told the New York Times that his
immigration talk is just that talk he
has too much to hide mr. Trump is
directing our anger for less than noble
purposes he creates scapegoats and
Muslims and Mexican immigrants this is
the very brand of anger that has led
other nations into the abyss Donald
Trump is a phony a fraud his promises
are as worthless as a degree from Trump
University this is a time for choosing
he has neither the temperament nor the
judgment to be President
his personal qualities would mean that
America would cease to be a shining city
on a hill